it was here at Westminster Abbey in
October last year that the Queen's
growing struggle with Mobility first
became obvious her daughter Anne handing
her mother a walking stick which she
would now need for support
It was 95 years old and the years were
finally catching up
and this deteriorating Health would mean
missing key engagements in November she
was forced to pull out of attending the
annual remembrance Sunday service at the
senator
and this blow came soon after the queen
was forced to spend a night at the King
Edward VII hospital it was her first
overnight stay in hospital for eight
years
by now the Monarch had been warned she
needed to slow down her busy diary
commitments it is been very clear all
the way through her Reign that she wants
to do
her best and she's you know taken an
oath that she has put first so
um she's she's done incredibly well
um and yeah I worked an awful lot longer
than most of the people in this world so
yeah well done
in her 96 years she has rarely been ill
she had surgery on her knees in 2003 and
was back in hospital in 2013 after a
bout of gastroenteritis even covid did
not seem to have a major impact on her
health
the queen caught the virus in February
2022 she told Medics and buried families
about the effect it had had on her it
does leave one very tired and exhausted
doesn't it but there were other things
that troubled her but Queen would never
share in public allegations surrounding
her son Andrew and a deepening family
Rift involving Harry and Megan which
would undoubtedly have caused her much
stress
but there is one major trauma that would
have impacted the Queen's Health like no
other the loss of her husband Prince
Philip in April last year
this heartbreaking image of a woman
separated from her life partner it can
only hint at the all-consuming grief the
Queen's gone through a really major life
event losing a life partner and it's not
uncommon that we hear stories that
people who have undergone such a loss
really find the following years really
very difficult
um and obviously grief has many effects
doesn't it on our um psychology but also
maybe on on other physiological aspects
like immune system it might also change
Behavior which then leads to changes in
muscle strength and ability to again
cope with those activities of daily
living so I guess there is going to be
an effect of losing a life partner
slowly showing the resilience that had
endeared her to Millions the queen
returned to public life albeit in a much
more limited way
her passions kept her going indulging
her love of horses in Windsor
and using a buggy to tour the Chelsea
flower show
these shorter engagements were just
about manageable by June however the
queen was forced to limit her
attendances at her own Jubilee
celebrations
[Music]
a month afterwards she undertook what
would be one of her last public
engagements the opening of a hospice in
Windsor
the decline in the Queen's Health was
slow and not easily noticeable just a
few days ago she received the new prime
minister 48 hours later her family
announced her death what happens with
somebody who is in their 90s or or is
frail is that even a small thing can
make a big difference something that
perhaps wouldn't have affected a younger
person with much more Reserve capacity
can really make a big difference and
cause someone to then become really very
unwell
a long happy rain a lifetime devoted to
her family and her subjects the Queen's
96 years were hardly troubled by ill
health and that will bring some small
Comfort to her grieving family Ashish
Joshi Sky News